Kon'nichiwa
Arigato gozaimasu,
We learned a lot of Japanese
Oh yeah;  A lot of great things from Our Japan trip
What is this intro  I always do this
I always- We're ENGAGED;
As you may have heard
I finally popped the question
I was thinking between you and Edgar and I decided
Last minute I'll go- I guess I'll go; Oh thank you
Now we're about to get married
So why don't we do a test- Let's do it!
To see if we are *Compatible*
To get married or not; Probably Not
So this is from marriage.com
I don't know why I say it like their sponsoring it
What are you expectations, What are your hopes, What are your thoughts
We're gonna be super compatible, and we're gonna be like-get married-easily! 100%!
Hopefully we'll be married by the end of this quiz.
How much of the time do you feel
Happy with the Person, Rarely- Oh My Gosh
50,70 or 90%
90% Percent; I agree Pound it brotha
Damn we need to slow down to get this video to 10 minutes
Do you agree on the number of kids you want to have
We haven't even talked about that, You  always check  here
There's like an Italian way- Well that' s like
A thing that kids do they see like this both things
They see like this both things Of your wrist that pop up
Too see how many kids your gonna have- Everyone is checking right now
How many kids are you gonna have??!?!
IHAVEZERO, I have one
Guess that means I'm gonna get CUCKED
That's One!- The Marriage is OVER!
Ok, So we haven't discussed, Not really, I think more or less is the answer though
More or Less Yeah, We're on the same page and We both don't know yet
There you go.
You disagree on a topic how do we solve this problem? We rarely disagree on things do we?
Yeah, I feel disappointed but avoid fighting
We agree to disagree
We eventually start fighting after trying to compromise
We resume straight to fighting
These are all terrible, I don't think-- We agree to disagree! I don't think so though
I feel like we just explain each other's point of view
That's agreeing to disagree
No, cause then we still find a thing together and we--
MY GOD
I DON'T WANT TO ARGUE WITH YOU RIGHT NOW
We Agreed To Disagree
How do you find their little quirks, what would be one of your quirks
That you shout in public.
That's a thing. If I don't record during a day, I go crazy
It leads to you shouting in public
Cause you challenge me to shout something awkward.
It's like the "Penis Game" , Yeah but I don't do it so you just do it for the fun of it
And to see me uncomfortable
I like making you uncomfortable. Yeah. Sometimes
Is that: Adorable, Funny, or
well, just little oddities
or annoying. I will say funny.
Your little quirks is that you never replace the toilet paper roll.
(giggling)
WHAT?
What's an actual... Don't touch me
This is not going great. What is a quirk for my lovely little Marzia?
How much you love Maya
Funny, let's go with funny
Do you feel comfortable around your partner
No, i always feel like I'm walking on eggshells
Jeez. If you're making them a quiz like this... That's crazy.
Not really, yeah most of the time
I can reveal my bad habits and weird parts
I mean, we were talking about poo right before you proposed. So yes, I'm pretty comfortable
Yeah, maybe a bit too comfortable
I would say. Yeah.
Literally I am about to pop the question
and you just be like, "I'm gonna have an amazing poo right now Felix". Yeah.
Yes. Have you ever noticed a red flag in your relationship
Once.
Multiple times, Once, Not sure, or Never
I don't know if I necessarily had like a..
big, big red flag
uhh-wha-me, I don't know like necessarily like
that one momment but maybe like, yeah, thought about it.
I guess you have that one time. I have one, yeah
It's that time that we went to
The premier? Yeah. And I just blew you off.
There was this choice of going to get your picture taken by you know, photographers
and being interviewed
or going from the back and just entering the cinema
and you were just like, "Oh, we'll see you inside"
and you just left me and wanted to get your photo taken.
I really wanted that photo I guess.
Well, it was more about the fact that you picked
going alone inside in front of cameras and like getting that celebrity moment
and that was like, woah, am I not your partner.
I guess that it was good that you had that
because i feel like it also made me realize
what's actually important
I don't think I saw it at that momment
I was like, yeah, I want to be in the spotlight
I couldn't careless about that sort of thing. Now.
Maybe that was a red flag for me too.
No, *laughing*
Once
This is going great
Does he or she try to limit the amount of time you spend with other people
uhh umm, no. What was that no? What was that no?
Sometimes i feel like, you're kinda like
you need to be back by this time.
Nonono, my only condition is that you don't come home drunk
Not at all.
Nonono, go a little, my partner is a but unhappy we're not
Oh, that's actually true though
No
We put on some extra pounds
does your partner support you?
Is that like weight?
Oh, is that what they mean. But they use money as a picture
If anything-- I guess I'm thinking a hypothetical scenario
what if you get really fat, then I will propose exercising together
But then again we already do go to the gym together
and stuff like that. Yeah, let's just do that one. Yeah.
You're running late, what's your partner's reaction?
uhh-nothing new
giggles
They call and ask me if I am OK
They call me the dinner's getting cold. They don't even notice
They make a big scene.
I call you to tell you that dinner's getting cold
Yeah, yeah, that makes sense.
Last question. Oh my gosh
Do you feel excited about this relationship?
That's the easiest one
Yes, very much
YOU ARE MEANT TOGETHEEER!
Wow
Even though we- I felt like we were doing bad
Just because we had to like bring up bad stuff from the past.
Obviously, we have fought like any other couple. I guess
This is weird talking about it.
I feel like we don't really actually fight that often
But if there's an issue
We talk about it. Yeah, we try to solve it.
and we get through it. I think that's how we really strengthen our relationship.
Yeah. And also the reason why I'm glad, like now's the perfect time
cause we're, we're so strong because of it.
Yeah. I'm glad we didn't
rush into our relationship, I mean, our engagement too soon
cause like, we're stronger than ever. Yeah.
well you be a good wife- of course i going to be
i want to know-lets see
do you care about other people-yes
yes.
i would like to try, not a
passion
no i
can't
it's not like i am taking care of you. we  like taking care of each other
but yea
have you volunteer in this field many times
no
i guess you would like to try
WHAT YOU MEAN I'm. I gave you seven years of my life.
I gave YOU seven years-yea
your partner decides he want to spend the evening with his best buds.what's your opinion?
great, it's important to give you space for sure-ok,ok
i wish we just said that last time it was weir-well you got weird about it
Yeah, I didn't realize...
How often do you nag and complain in a relationship?
What does tha- What does nag mean?
Like, small complaint
{giggles)
It's not at me though, is it?
I feel like you get frustrated sometimes and maybe
at something else and then I'm the punching bag.